[Music]
my name is sue and I'm currently manager
and data scientist at the Rockefeller
Foundation so the foundation as many of
other folks here are I think foundation
of philanthropic ventures so we
basically provide a lot of granted
funding to a lot of NGOs mostly in
developing countries and before I used
to be a data scientist at BuzzFeed and
before that very consistent career I was
doing genetics at hospital here in New
York I also hold well I have a degree in
statistics from the University of
Melbourne in Australia so this is why my
accent is a slightly strange now
something that I want to talk to you is
like a motivating question for these
kinds of models because the reasons why
you want to use these kind of models is
depending on the sort of questions that
you want to analyze alright so I'm from
Mexico and recently I was visiting my
parents I go there fairly often and
something that people have been
complaining in the last couple of months
or years the last 2-3 years has been the
case of dengue in the state where I'm
from and so well dengue has become
climate change temperature is rising in
the country so especially in in urban
areas so it's a much more prone
environment for mosquito-borne diseases
so we're gonna talk briefly about that
as an example to understand why will you
use these intrinsic models and there are
a couple of problems that we face with
with these kinds of spatial analysis the
conditional or regressive models like
how do you state the model the intrinsic
part of it
and finally the implementation in a
probabilistic software called Stan which
actually is developed here at Columbia
University a lot of developers are in
this university so thank you very much
if you're
so in the audience so the motivated
question here something that you want to
think about is the policy question in
this sense right and so for instance we
have a bunch of if you go back in time
these are the yearly cases of dengue
reported in the state of Jalisco in
Mexico so as you can see there have been
a couple of spikes in the past and so
currently the spike that you see here is
this year and the year hasn't ended so
it's very likely I think the numbers
here were up until September so it's
very likely that they might reach there
five five and a half thousand cases so
it has become a bit of an issue for
Public Health so here is a state it's
very weakly a little potentially
gerrymandering discussion too we have
now this data as you can see this is
actually plotting the the dengue case
like the areas that are very severely
affected by thinking in in the state and
so for instance these areas the actual
capital in urban area it's just right
here where I'm pointing there are a lot
of cases than the coast as well the area
that you don't see as many cases is in
the northern area there's a lot of
mountains probably very unlikely that
mosquitoes like those areas but
something that I want you to be aware of
is that in Mexico it's very especially
in this state where I'm from it's very
common for people in our towns to come
to the city to seek health assistance
for sight dengue so we have to be
mindful that if there are a lot of
dengue cases reported in the city it
might not be well one bit because
there's a lot of people more likely to
be dengue but also because a lot of
people from towns that are out of the
city are coming to be treated in the
city so those cases are reported
probably in the city as opposed to where
they actually are
nated now one of the things that I was
surprised is that the state actually
keeps a really good app for how to get
polygon data which is what you need to
map to do a pre plot like the one that I
just show you here so you can actually
obtain the polygon and here's the link
if you want to explore a little bit they
also have a pretty cool app for
accessing all these databases but I'm a
little bit is at the different level so
for instance you can have the national
level the municipality level which is
kind of the equivalent about County in
the States
and so for instance here you can
download all the cases of dengue
annually you can also download them
monthly at the municipal level so it's
quite a very nice app not a lot of
information yet but nevertheless quite
useful so if you're interested in what
sort of other variables they have here
is the link in I'll be I already have
the slides online if you want to explore
so however why we can't have nice things
with this spatial data one of the things
is a spatial autocorrelation and so
let's briefly talk about autocorrelation
in general so as a good example is like
you measure your weight today you
measured tomorrow and you measure it for
so many years ahead so it's very likely
that your weight today is very similar
to the one tomorrow
right so these are in case of like
they're very close together because you
taking those measurements very close in
time however if you look at your way
today and then in three five years it's
very unlikely that is very similar
unless you like a person that is looking
after his weight for if he is very very
consistent and all that so good luck
with that so in this case temporal
autocorrelation is you have measurements
that are close in time and therefore
they're very close to each other
now spatial autocorrelation is a bit
much more complicated not only because
unlike time that is just going forward
it's much much more dimensionally right
and so at least you have two dimensions
and so spatial autocorrelation describes
the extent to which a measurement is
actually very similar to the neighboring
regions as opposed to distant regions so
in this case you respect like I just
show you before in this map that the
cases of dengue are very cluster because
guess what mosquitoes don't really care
about your gerrymandering preferences
they just fly to wherever the heck they
want and so it's very likely that they
will fly across different neighboring
areas now one of the motivating
questions that I had here was my
grandparents live in a very rural area
and this is a very common infrastructure
that the government builds at the state
level to collect water for cattle and
agricultural purposes and very
interesting this is a sort of data that
is actually available at the state level
and at the municipal level so the state
collects sort of the infrastructure like
how much capacity can these pond have
and you can download this this air and
this data set so one of the questions
that you might think is like well this
this called pond seemed like a perfect
like ideal house for mosquito houses I
guess and so in this case a very simple
model that you want to consider is like
well how does this water storage
capacity that is used for agricultural
purposes impacts a number of cases of
dengue right and so we also have like
this model is very simple because say we
only have this coverage but we know that
there's also a bunch of all there
everything else that affects the amount
of number of cases means you might run a
regression it can be in this case
some regressions is you're considering
counts but if you have a different kind
of measure continues then you you can
consider any kind of other GLM models
now another let's think a little bit
further right extend from the simple
modeling to say we have a bunch of all
the covariance as well and so for
instance you can take a bunch of good
draw like population density may be
income may be other covariance that
using that will be appropriate to
consider you temperature you know so all
these kind of data sets are very
important to have as control they affect
also they could have an interaction with
the water capacity a variable that we're
considering but we know that there's
also everything else right that you know
considering it will probably fall in
your errors right so consider these now
what happens when everything else also
contains these a spatial autocorrelation
that I was talking about what happens is
that it partly chops in my slides but
basically we are trying to fit a model
that assumes that the errors are
uncorrelated right however when we have
this autocorrelation happening in
spatial data this is spatial
autocorrelation might be absorbed by one
of your estimates or you might end up in
your errors but at the end of the day
you're estimating in reality a model
that the Epsilon's are not zero and so
in this case what happens is that a new
[ __ ] like very much more common that you
expect you will see these errors these
kind of mistakes done in a lot of
spatial analysis and what happens is
that at the end of the day your
estimates for the covariance will be
ultimately quite wrong and so this
happens for instance when everything
else again affects these this say for
instance in this model that we have what
is everything else that can affect also
the water storage capacity well it could
be that there were rural areas they have
more cattle and having more animal I
guess
affecting the amount of dengue but also
it affects how many these of these water
storage ponds are built right because
they use for agriculture as well so it's
just like it affects both your coverage
and the outcome now in this case there's
a way that you can measure this level
autocorrelation and his cormorants or a
correlation statistic and the idea of
this is basically measure how the
neighboring regions are deviating from
your current measurement right and so we
can just for the sake of time I want to
keep this in a more comfortable way so
basically for this data said you can you
can estimate this statistic and if you
see well ideally if it they're not
correlated you will see all of them
scattered very nicely with a flat line
there's no correlation here however for
these data we do have some special
little correlation and I mean you would
say like so that's obvious because in
the map you can see it the region's are
like there but with their stations we
don't just like look at these maps and
say look trust me right I mean that
would be sometimes the way of waste but
it doesn't happen then so in this case
generally what these Maran statistic
takes is your current measurement and so
what you do is say okay so how many
neighbors do I have I have say four
neighbors and so you can there are
different ways in which your account for
instance if one of your neighbors is
much larger in area than others you can
apply a different way to that neighbor
but in this case for simplicity you can
just assign them the same weight and say
well whatever there are cases of dengue
in my neighboring regions and scale them
by the number of neighbors and in the
way that you've provided and so you want
to see this port to to see how those
cases are somehow distributed among your
neighbors and now when we
there's this moran test when basically
if we permute a number of dengue cases
and just like do a random permutation
you would expect that a random a random
distribution of those cases would sort
of like test the idea that there's no
correlation between my neighbors cases
and my and my number of cases but this
is kind of the distribution that if you
randomly permute those those numbers
then you get a distribution that
basically looks like this that this
distribution says if there was no
correlation this is what your
distribution will look like however that
dotted line that you see is actually my
value of the Moran statistic which is
quite extreme and so if you wanted to do
more like a testing of the usual p-value
you can get that in the case of this
distribution is actually Monte Carlo
simulations and you can plot those
simulations and if you want to get a
p-values similar just because a lot of
people understand p-values better what I
think they do you can also get that but
basically you can see how many of those
simulations have below the point where
your statistic is right and so in this
case we have 500 I'd run 601 simulation
and 597 of those are below in my point
so it's quite extreme as you can see so
therefore we expect to see this
correlation but you might think but so
is this really a problem you just making
this out like I mean a wish but
unfortunately this is much more common
that we expect and so for instance this
economists publish a paper just a few
months ago about the standard errors of
persistence and so persistence is
basically the sort of studies that say
that sort of roughly let's look at the
variable in some very
in the past and how these variables in
the past affect the future and so in a
lot of these studies they're actually
look I think redlining was a very clear
example of these and so basically a lot
of them have spatial analysis but
unfortunately a lot of these are
severely bias in the sense that he went
back and review a bunch of papers he's a
list of different papers and he said
well none of these reported this Moran
statistic let's let's just go back and
have a look and so he basically
estimated estimated this statistic and
added some random noise and sometimes
when adding random noise he found that
the random noise gave was like getting
more signal than the actual estimates
that some of these papers were claiming
so again like this story here is that if
you're working with spatial statistics
be very mindful that a lot of these even
if they're kind of contained in in
regions they might not necessarily be
uncorrelated because in spatial
statistics we have a continuum of
characteristics among like from one
street to another so just be mindful of
this kind of correlation because you
will mess up your results so one way to
account for days will be using
conditional order regressive models and
so this kind of models have generally
used for spatial data they have widely
used in ecology economics and
epidemiology and they were it was first
developed in the 70s by a British
statistician now some of the
specifications for car models are
basically a finite set of
non-overlapping units so in this case if
you have different regions making sure
that they don't have this overlap or
like spatial overlap
for it could be for instance number of
car accidents in a county level so
generally they tend to be count data but
you can also have continuous data or
binary data for that matter and so the
specification of this you can see it
here but basically let's have an n total
number of regions where we want to know
which regions are adjacent to the others
so that's very simple just a sign of
wine if we neighbors if we're not
neighbors then Sarah and so this
relationship unfortunately you can see
here they symmetric in the sense that if
I'm your neighbor and you're my neighbor
we only want to assign one edge as
opposed to two different edges because
we're not this is a node directed graph
okay so but it's not reflexive meaning
that I'm not a neighbor of myself so in
this case they so imagine a hexagon map
like this where we have this this region
since so you want to build these weight
matrix which is like who is my neighbor
and in this case we're only interested
in the upper triangular area to assign
the edges because we only need one edge
so for instance if you see in in one and
and to hear their neighbors but we're
only going to have one edge between
these two are supposed to say unique
edges now there are the matrix that you
will be interested is to know how many
neighbors do I have and this is a
diagonal matrix this one will contain
the number of adjacent spatial units
that you have and I don't know why my
slides are all messed up but the basic
idea is that you end up with a model
that is actually quite simple
and I can work like let me check it's
basically normally distributed it's
quite nicely so you have here your your
weight matrix which is there who is my
neighbor your zero one matrix you have
the
matrix here so these will be your
precision matrix okay and so in this
case it's a multivariate distribution
this and this alpha here controls the
strength of the special association with
zero meaning that there's no dependence
so that they're completely independent
you really want to use this because for
obvious reason that I've just been
talking about spatial data is generally
quite correlated so what is intrinsic
part of I cotton in this case the
intrinsic part again you can't see it
here but they're basically the main
difference is just that this alpha is
actually set to 1 meaning that they're
fully like they're perfectly dependent
right so this is pretty much the only
difference in this model unfortunately
you can see it here but the problem with
this setting up this equal to 1 is that
this matrix here it's not invertible
anymore that's a that's a huge problem
for covariance matrices and so in this
case what you want to do in some well
something that was suggested by julien
beside and encourage that you can
constrain the sum of Phi's you can't see
it here unfortunately to 0 so you can
constrain 1 you can apply this
constraint in order to make these these
matrix to be a bit more manageable and
so at the end of the day if you want to
work at the derivation this is like a
math assignment for homework but I will
be posted in this lives as well so
basically you end up with the proposed
with the Joint Distribution with your
spatial autocorrelation is modeled as a
sum of different adjacent the difference
between adjacent regions and so you can
easily implement this model instead so
if you're not familiar with Stan is an
open source probabilistic
programming language and as I mentioned
here is it a lot of the developers live
here it will not Li but they develop
here at Columbia so one of the things
that you want to have in mind with Stan
is that it calculates log probabilities
because then you will run into numerical
problems if you start multiplying a
bunch of tiny numbers so ideally just
think about in this case that Stan will
estimate these log probabilities the
usual structure and you have many more
blocks and the ones that I'm putting
here but generally you have a data block
here where you have all the vectors
matrices pieces of data that you have
but you will define here whether there
are vector matrix had is how the data
are going to be inputted in this in the
model and then you have the parameters
which are the parameters that we are
going to estimate and finally you have a
model so in this case say you have a
normal distribution you can assign prior
values to these distributions mu and
Sigma so you can do it down as well in
your model in the model section so for
this icon model because it's not a very
well-defined distribution given that
it's not like we put this constraint the
matrix without this constraint is not
invertible we might be able to use this
as a prior instead and so the way that
you want to model your data instant for
this
Genki problem for instance is well we
have the number of observations we you
have your descent sorry we have the
number of variables that we want to use
the number of unique edges well not
unique sorry the number of undirected
edges and you want to see also the node
the nodes that are connected so for
instance node 1 in region 1 is connected
its neighbored with region 2 and so on
so you you define that relationship in
these nodes in the rest of the data
in you functions here so if you remember
how at the end of the day this I car and
there have been this expression here
that I had before in two slides before
so you can add it as a function that
then can be taken as a prior in your
model and so some of the very simple
model that we we're going to identify
instead will be just having our
intercept in this case I used the water
capacity of these ponds I use population
density and an interaction term between
these two variables because it could be
that ponds are very large in areas when
there is no population so you want to
know this interaction weather is
valuable to have or not and finally your
special effects which is this iechyd
component and finally heap here you have
your model we model it as a Poisson
regression and so it's very simple you
as I mention here you have your
intercept your design matrix the ikat
component and the variance and this log
here that you see is something that is
normally used in Poisson models which is
the exposure and so for instance this
exposure is generally used to adjust for
the rate and so I'll give you an example
so for instance there's an intersection
if we're doing like number of accidents
in and say different street
intersections it could be that you have
50 accidents in one intersection but 50
accidents is different if you have like
say ten thousand cars going through that
intersection as if you have say I don't
know a thousand cars right so it's quite
different this rate is quite different
and it's something that you want to
include in your in your in your Poisson
model and so this e is basically the
variable that we use it for an exposure
so in this case I used just general
population numbers and log it and
unfortunately you can see here but
it basically you feel in a a Poisson
regression here and something that you
wanna see like when I was reading these
this paper by Kelly is like how
different the estimates could be if you
have your iCard component and if you
don't have it so how different out those
measurements and so you can for instance
feed initially a just a very simple
model like the one that I showed you in
the ended in the tag so just wonder has
the the water component as a CO varied
and nothing else and everything else
falls in the errors so you can have that
we can also add more variables in this
case population density and have maybe
the interaction between the two of them
without the I component just yet and
then finally you can fit the I car
component as well in in the model as I
can't it in standing then see how
different those those results are and so
basically like you I mean I just put the
results here of the difference between
the last two models the one with the
covariance and interactions with them
with that the I component so model
unfortunately is like should be three so
model two is with other i car component
and model 3 is with your i car component
in this case so as you can see it's
quite thick quite not super different
but for instance water capacity which is
something that I was considering could
be a part of this dengue outbreaks turns
out that is not it's actually quite on
the negative side if we if we use our
ikat component so it's not really
contributed much to these cases whereas
population density seems to be a much
more problematic not problematic but a
much more interesting explanatory
component in this case and this is where
a very very over simplified model
something that I will speak in a second
so the interceptors were
wildly different wildly different
actually and so in the interaction
component is not much different as we
can see this probably that tends the
population density plane a little bit
there into that component to bring it to
zero now some think that these are
pretty much older slides
something that I wanted to consider for
this model in well that I still want so
it's very early stages for the work that
we're doing with these is basically we
want to speak to the Bureau of
Meteorology of Mexico to see what the
temperatures are in these different
regions but that work on its own will
require a little bit more work because a
lot of these stations are actually not
as basically they're just scattered
across the state so not all the regions
that are sure you will have a weather
station that collects a precipitation
and temperature so we will have to
probably some of the stations are like
for the whole region which are generally
quite big so we want to know for
instance how much can we extrapolate the
measurements of these these weather
stations in the state to basically
incorporate these temperature and
climate data into these models to make
it a bit more accurate but to be honest
as well like it seems also that is a
very like it has been very like even
with the problems that the Daiya is
reported mostly in the cities still
we've seen a lot of the prevalence of
mosquito diseases in the city so it
might be worth considering having those
I believe that the city the capital of
this state has at least four or five
different weather stations precisely
because you want to have more accurate
measures in areas that are much more
populated to sort of manage a lot of
these cases better but um so that's
basically it and there's a bunch of
resources here that I put it so if
you're dealing with a lot of space
data a lot of the time you want to have
an easy way to process this data to say
you have a neighbor that has no it's not
like Mexican could have the whole
country you want to figure out this
graph and who's the neighbors you don't
want to do that but visually so there's
a couple of packages that you can use
and it's literally I was even wondering
whether to do it with the municipalities
instead of the region level thank you
Jim for the suggestion he sent me a
couple of links to this SP DEP package
so that there's like different ways in
which you can also if like the area is
neighboring or one point is there are
different ways in which you could
structure these these adjacency matrix
but there are tools that can make it
easy for you to to deal with this data
and I highly recommend to use the SF
package if you use in in if you're
working in R as a package makes the
spatial data spatial features really
light so it's something that you can
actually run locally which is something
that we've been doing with a computer so
we don't need to spin any AWS just yet
but it's it's doable and thank you
[Music]
you don't need all that work for me
yeah so there's quite a few I believe
that the same package might do a
distance matrix from different points
generally in spatial data you might do
it from the centroid to the other
centroid but I believe that it might
take you a couple of lines of more work
to do it from different parts of the
polygon to a different part of the
polygon and work out some distances but
yeah I believe that package s P DP can
do it for you I'm not sure yet I would
like to introduce a precipitation as
part of it because this is only water
capacity right it doesn't really mean
that they're full or they have so this
is something that precipitation
information could actually help me to
pinpoint more accurately but yeah this
is this is still under works yeah thank
you
[Music]